[Música]
es el tiempo que se come para darle
coherencia
quizás hemos vamos
felicidades
[Música]
ah
ahora el sábado
[Música]
o sea algo
en otras actividades de otras
actividades de conocimiento
[Música]
y bueno este llamado lo cojo que el
terreno
[Aplausos]
una vez
y bueno por la excepcionalidad porque es
la que está conciente
viene del verde
[Música]
y sin él
s
a ser un residente de la verdad en el
que no vamos a hacer es comenzar las
ideas
sí
es bajar la imaginación baja los sueños
bajarlo
i
bien ustedes comen
hay un registro con esta con esa palabra
pasando los días
ellos de las cuevas
acerca de ellos como lo conocimos
también a esto es algo que vamos a
llegar precisamente
ah
es decir las personas
más ricos
[Música]
vamos a ver
o no
cuando se enteró de nada
por qué
una
una vez muy buena
[Música]
i
y además de esta actividad
en el amor y bueno parece que tengo
no es eso lo que aquí no tiene sanción
que la nación
y cosas así así lo mejor
tenía problemas con las otras cosas de
manera extra de alguna manera mencionó
es la que es
como en el mundo de la especialidad
así
bueno
cuándo
cuando aporta 7 para que éste también
hacemos otro en este caso
es una persona en el edificio
además de acciones para cada una de
estas normas se apresten a muchas de las
cosas
con estas cosas
/
[Música]
bien
es decir es como si a un punto ciego
aquí tenemos los problemas de los
conversos
en general
vamos a personal
y eso
[Música]
cómo
identificamos
será
cuándo
ahora la extracción de la polis
empezamos
consistentes a partir de distintos
conocimientos que tenemos
[Música]
ingresa al médico completo
la actividad de entrenamiento compártelo
es difícil de imaginar
esa canción
american era mi posición que todas las
cosas era muy consciente de las
tecnologías no es sólo cosa de la
política
también es una de las más evidentes
le diría muchas cosas pero al menos eso
grados de telecinco debe ser comenzamos
a sacar ese personaje
[Música]
en su historia
y
[Música]
yo le han demostrado gracias de la
necesidad
[Música]
tal es el caso de la semana
qué bueno pues es una manera de que
comprase una medida complicada
el sector de la masía
el pse no sabía mucho sobre el mundial y
nos enteramos que por temáticas
sabían cuáles eran sabía la mente
entonces
hay cuántas maneras de ver si no buenas
maneras de decir simple
no no
porque la verdad
se ponían todos
y bueno a lo largo de la historia
la era del pasado ahora más sensible que
hacemos nosotros
a veces el ambiente
de esta manera que los 40 dice que el
social manera la estructura
servando diga
una cosa es entender esos sistemas
y eso dejará llegando como una expresión
[Música]
porque sólo es parte de lo que tenía que
hacer
algo que conocemos
en el caso de que no se supriman a
pensar de una manera
así se conoce 4
tratamiento
pero no fue diseñado que también los
mejores del mundo
y los demás no acierta es muchísimo
manera más fuerte después de que la vida
de los otros son el centro
ojo lenguaje de plastilina roja
nos interesa más la conversión
así de estar así
[Música]
y una jornada de recuperación de la
bolsa local
el arte y las ciencias
por ejemplo por qué
[Música]
no es sagrado
sí
tres cantos
[Música]
con otras que no
el cargamento será competente también
cuando usted es del territorio nacional
saben de lo que sea
no sé por qué decir
en la estación de bomberos ya sea el
recordado del embajador o recordado para
siempre
ya que aparecen las gracias porque son
ejemplos
qué bueno
como nosotros tenemos con nuestros
propios pensamientos
bien
por qué
les voy a comentar
dónde está
trabajando seguimos viendo la música
los animales
algunos puntos sobre la realidad y no sé
cómo explicar la verdad es que no sé
cómo son las frases en las primas
en la media de las naciones
en la vida
sí
esas mujeres
en estos días de sedes y lograr
y una cosa que será menos que significa
la pieza de la memoria
la diosa del amor
que haya conocido
no me detengo limitarse a ser detenido
hasta crecer en el que la memoria de los
que trabajan por ciento
y es de estas necesidades básicas
a clases y las ciencias
la verdad es que sí
s
cuando escuchamos las grabaciones a
veces hablamos
tienes que responder ante nadie
la música de ejemplo para estar
presentes
37 los medios imágenes o días
a veces en la cara
[Música]
la música - a partir de 2000 y así lo
dice nuestra francés
y el s
la música ya la tenemos
y esas cosas
esa instalación
cuando las cosas son como son la razón
por la que permanece
la señora de la colocación de sangre
en ese mes
es
[Música]
porque si no la gente
la cuestión de la vida
y con fascinación por la música era lo
referente a cómo se siente
así era
bien
de forma física
y esas mercancías
y resulta que cuando
una vez que escuchamos música de la vez
350 veremos antes
impresionante es el mensaje de que
intentamos entender
en esencia es el mismo
y qué
una canción que yo
pero que generaría de las gracias por
las artes y las ciencias
ahora sr
ojalá que no
ya sea en el expediente para esclarecer
si eras
tiene sentimientos a los expertos y
nuestra diversidad
parece ser que las estaciones agradece
por ese género
de las necesitadas también sea una
muerte
de la gente
y como nadie
cuando por primera vez sacar a la gente
si la gente tiene muchas
sobre las autonomías de los casinos es
que estuviéramos en realidad incluso por
temáticas
para que sea nuestro fin es informar
entonces
por la música de conocimientos y
conciencia también
a veces pero le gustaría agradecer este
lugar ya veces no
bueno
[Música]